for us query will be the most complex of
the required content provider methods
we've given you the bones of the query
operation as you can see we use our s
URI matcher object once again to switch
on the type of URI note that each
response from this function will return
a cursor that corresponds to the
incoming query as defined by the URI
this is the only function where we will
have to fill out a different response
for every type of URI in the content
provider as several of them are used in
queries only at the bottom of our
function we're going to set the
notification URI for our cursor to the
one that was passed into the function
this causes the cursor to register a
Content observer to watch for changes
that happen to that URI and any of its
descendants this allows the content
provider to easily tell the UI when the
cursor changes on operations like a
database insert or update will see more
on this later when we cover inserting
and updating the database uncomment the
test basic weather query function within
test provider and run this code when
you're finished to make sure all of this
is working well